the increasing incidence of hostile
acquired staphylococcal infection is
prompting nurses and other medical
personnel to re-evaluate procedures
employed in patient care
since most disease producing organisms
are destroyed when proper septic
procedures are used hand-washing is
considered the most practical and
consistent defense against the spread of
infection the following scenes
demonstrate an accepted method requiring
60 to 90 seconds to perform hand-washing
should include the forearms up to the
area pointed out by the nurse using
either cake or liquid soap first rather
the hands thoroughly then rub the dorsal
and Palmer surfaces applying
approximately ten friction movement next
interlace the fingers and cleanse the
interdigital spaces again with pen
friction movements
now soak the forearms and rub each for
10 to 15 seconds
always rinse carefully allowing the
water to flow from fir'aun's toward the
fingertips
after repeating the hand-washing
procedure clean the fingernails a
toothpaste may be used for this purpose
dry the hands and forearms thoroughly
with a paper towel then with a dry
portion of the towel turn off the water
faucet to prevent skin irritation
complete the hand washing with an
application of a suitable lotion or
cream